jimmy fella is the host of fox across
america with jimmy bailey joins us
tonight jimmy hey this is a problem for
the post yo
this is my favorite thing in the world
the idea that this snuck into the
washington post tucker
apparently jeff bezos put the brick and
mortar editors out of business too
because they should have caught this
it's absurd uh and it's such a
self-owned but i want to start at the
tippy top man this whole idea of
declaring war on dead presidents drives
me personally crazy because george
washington by the standard of the day he
lived in number one was an outstanding
human being but number two this is
personal my son
is named lincoln i have one kid tucker
uh we decided to stop breeding after the
first report card we were like you know
what we should probably get a dog or
something
this isn't working out but i have a son
named lincoln and even his name is
controversial now so he's going by his
middle name oj but no think about this
really stick with me here because this
drives me crazy everybody that tries to
point out our past okay is also
highlighting our progress when they do
it what did this op-ed say oh in 1821 it
was whites only at george washington
university sure it was and we don't love
that but no nation has worked harder to
improve it fast forward to 2022 the only
place left that's whites only is sheldon
whitehouse's country club there's no
other place where they're excluding
black people but this is the thing
tucker uh woke democrats are cultural
arsonists they like to find new forms of
oppression set little societal fires so
they can extinguish them and then claim
valor and virtue but the trick is none
of it helps the black community so when
you think about the black community
right now tucker they're being plagued
by failing schools and astonishingly
high rates of violent crime nowhere
tonight as a guy who's getting crushed
by inflation getting mugged for those
overpriced goods going if only buddy
somebody could stop by and rename a
statue or you know what i mean rename a
school and that's the part that drives
me crazy man
well they're you're right they're
arsonists they only destroy they never
build build your own impressive country
your own impressive school but they
can't they can only wreck things that
other people made well that's a great
point that's the host it's so much
easier tucker to sell victimhood to the
black community right than it is to sell
them progress really quick this is new
when barack obama ran for president what
was the motto yes we can if he showed up
now in the age of incentivized
victimhood with yes we can they'd be
like yo yes we can check your privilege
half white guy what do you mean yes we
can and that's the part that's so stupid
well it's unbelievably stupid and you
know get back to me when you build
something worth having that's what i
always think when they jimmy thanks so
much great to see you tonight doctor
you're the man
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight